nos piden que encontremos la distancia
entre los siguientes puntos pausa en el
vídeo y traten de resolverlo hay muchas
maneras de abordar este problema en
realidad yo lo haré tratando de dibujar
un triángulo rectángulo en el que la
línea que conecta estos puntos sea la
hipotenusa y luego podremos usar el
teorema de pitágoras dejen de mostrarles
de qué estoy hablando
voy a dibujar un triángulo rectángulo
aquí
esta es la altura de mi triángulo
esta es la anchura de mi triángulo y
luego la hipotenusa conectará estos dos
puntos
usaré mi herramienta regla para conectar
este punto con este otro punto y dibujar
una línea anaranjada
muy bien
tengo un triángulo rectángulo en el que
la línea que conecta estos dos puntos es
la hipotenusa
por qué sirve hacer esto a partir de
este punto pueden pausar el vídeo y
tratar de encontrar la longitud de esta
línea anaranjada que es la distancia
entre estos dos puntos cual es la
longitud de esta línea roja podemos
verla en esta cuadrícula es igual a 2
hay exactamente 2 espacios y también
podemos pensar en estas distancias en
términos de coordenadas la coordenada de
este punto que tenemos aquí es menos 58
menos 58 la coordenada que tenemos aquí
es x es 4 y 6-4
y luego la coordenada que tenemos aquí
va a tener la misma coordenada y ya que
este punto
que 6 y va a tener la misma coordenada x
que este punto esta coordenada es menos
56 fíjense que sólo estamos cambiando la
dirección en ye y le estamos cambiando
por 2 cuál es la longitud de esta línea
podemos contar 123456789 es 9 o también
podemos verlo en las coordenadas estamos
cambiando el valor de x y vamos de menos
5 de x menos 5 hasta x 4 vamos a
incrementarlo en 9 todo esto nos prepara
para que podamos usar el teorema de
pitágoras si llamamos a este lado c
sabemos que a cuadrada más b cuadrada es
igual a c cuadrada o podemos decir que 2
al cuadrado
+ 9 al cuadrado
es igual a nuestra hipotenusa al
cuadrado que le voy a llamar se va a ser
igual a c cuadrada que en realidad es la
distancia que es la que estamos tratando
de calcular 2 al cuadrado es 4 y 9 al
cuadrado es igual a 81
todo esto es igual a c cuadrada
y tenemos que ser cuadrada es igual a 85
se cuadrada es igual a 85 11 es igual a
la raíz cuadrada de 85 pueda simplificar
está un poco déjenme ver cuántas veces
cabe 5 en 85 déjenme ver cabe 17 veces y
ninguno de los dos son cuadrados
perfectos bueno esto es 50 + 35 pero
creo que esta es la manera más simple de
escribirlo
si quieren expresar lo como un decimal
podrían escribirlo en su calculadora y
definir qué tan preciso lo quieren esto
que tenemos aquí es la longitud de esta
línea la hipotenusa de nuestro triángulo
rectángulo pero principalmente por la
pregunta que nos hacen es la distancia
entre estos dos puntos